you went to a place that I have been to
recently I went to Berlin not long ago
you went went to Germany is that right
to promote the movie yeah we went all
over Europe but a stop and a stop in
Germany which is nice for me because I
have I I know how to speak a little bit
of German it's Pratt Pratt must be a is
it a German name no I don't I don't
believe it is I don't believe it is
I don't believe Pratt's German yeah I
know that in England it means douche and
slowly and I was getting a Herrick in
English I'm turning it into that as well
you're doing everything you can to have
that become the name for it in England
that's great yeah but but yeah so yeah
you bend it so you're in Germany and you
speak how much German do you speak I do
okay I know and you want to hear a joke
in German you know a joke in German yeah
you won't get it all right let's share
this nope in German I'm at okay curious
okay okay so details I know capitis it's
not bad on open Peter says dieter sister
ologies a house I think about it is a
husband might Harnack about on a by its
height each pizza D house about nine on
and cystic here Jacob medication women
Harnack about how she tears due to the
repeated acacia power nine on there now
I have a day across Melbourne
hand-ground ICC eights eat him all about
nine
[Applause]
right yeah that worked great can we know
what the joke is in English yeah it has
the f-word in it is that okay yeah so
far yeah so dieter and his grandfather
Peter are sitting on a mountain side and
Peter says look down there you see all
those houses I built those houses with
my bare hand but did they call me Peter
the house builder no and you see the
church I built that church with my bare
hands do they call me Peter the house
builder no and the wall I worked on that
wall I built it stone by stone with my
bare hands do they call me Peter the
wall builder no but you one Pig
[Music]
[Applause]
kind of say I love that when you say it
in when you said it in German and you
said to the last line you gave it a
little bit of Germany the last line in
German really nice that it's a
grandfather just the kind of thing you
want to say - yeah I love that that's
fantastic
thank you let's hope I get you in
trouble oh you're gonna get in a lot of
trouble
that's not my problems with the German
pork board
yeah
[Applause]
you